à orléans le président giscard d'estaing
pour la première pierre d'un urbanisme
naturel et démocratique
raymond barre écrite à jacques chirac
avant le sommet de la majorité demain
deux rendez vous diplomatiques pour
giscard demain avec l'italien andretti
et l'allemand schmitt des triches sera
au vainqueur inattendu de la 16e étape
du tour de france
bonsoir qui n'a jamais eu de problème de
logement dans sa vie qui ne s'est jamais
dit au moins une fois mon appartement
est trop petit ou bien mon loyer trop
cher au mieux je voudrais acheter une
maison bien peu d'entre nous s'en douter
c'est pourquoi monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing a longuement insisté ce matin
à orléans sur l'importance de la réforme
du logement dont il annonçait la mise en
application prochaine objectif de cette
réforme a expliqué le chef de l'état
ouvrir la voie à un urbanisme naturel et
démocratique il faut permettre à tous de
se loger dans de bonnes conditions selon
la formule de son choix dans 12
départements pilotes dont le loiret une
aide personnalisée au logement va être
mis en place dès cette année 220 mille
familles pourront en profiter dès
l'année prochaine
c'est une véritable conquête sociale a
déclaré le président de la république en
installant par ailleurs le conseil
national de l'accession à la propriété
organisme qui devrait permettre à
beaucoup plus de français de devenir
propriétaires
avant d'expliquer les grandes lignes de
cette réforme du logement valéry giscard
d'estaing s'est rendu ce matin a rendu
visite plutôt à l'une des premières
familles bénéficiaires de cette aide
personnalisée
la visite présidentielle commence par ce
lotissement hlm de la commune de la
ferté-saint-aubin à une trentaine de
kilomètres d'orléans
c'est là que s'est installée depuis
moins d'une semaine dans un quatre
pièces de 80 m² la famille de monsieur
guy audio officiellement la première à
bénéficier de la nouvelle eve
personnalisée au logement
logement et livré tout fait
moquette papier tout est prêt oui
monsieur guy audio à trois enfants il
est de sa profession maçon carreleur
pour lui l'application de la nouvelle
loi se traduit ainsi il perd à 340
francs sur un loyer total de 950 cap
flou après une demi-heure dans le quatre
pièces cuisine devenu l'exemple concret
d'une aide personnalisée au logement le
chef de l'état serrer quelques mains
tendues puis poursuivait devant les élus
régionaux une explication plus complète
de la loi de décembre 1976 réformant
l'aide au logement
objectif numéro un de la réforme
remplacer l'aide à la pierre c'est à
dire le financement de certains types de
logements sociaux par l'aide à la
personne qui personnalisait tient compte
davantage des situations particulières
et des besoins familiaux
chiffres clés à retenir 4000 francs
c'est le revenu mensuel familiale en
dessous duquel l'aide au logement sera
le plus efficace
un exemple un ménage de deux enfants
disposent avec un seul salaire d'un
revenu mensuel de 3 mille francs
actuellement pour louer un quatre pièces
dans une hlm se ménage paix 763 francs
de loyer perçoit une aide de 309 francs
dans le nouveau système de loyers
augmentent parce que l'aide à la pierre
diminue mais l'aide directe aux ménages
progresse encore plus vite
actuellement les forts de ce ménage de
454 francs par mois avec l'apl il tombe
à 3 111 francs
l'aide personnalisée au logement servir
à la location d'un logement mais aussi à
son achat elle sera utilisée dans les
logements neufs et parfois dans les
anciens une critique au nouveau système
au dessus de 4000 francs de revenus
mensuels les aides diminuent pour aider
davantage les petits revenus ou pénalise
les moyens à terme certaines
organisations comme les hlm entre
l'agression rectangulaire et pointue des
grands ensembles et la dilution
pavillonnaire à travers le paysage entre
les outrances collectiviste et
l'individualisme forcené
il y as place en france pour une
troisième voie celle qui a jadis façonné
nos villes et nos villages et que
j'appelle l'urbanisme naturel
j'ai demandé au ministre de l'équipement
et de l'aménagement du territoire et au
ministre de la culture d'encourager
vigoureusement cette troisième voie
je constate que déjà des architectures
que les spécialistes dénomme habitat
intermédiaire
habitats semi collectifs maisons
individuelles groupées ou maisons de
ville sont expérimentées ici et là grâce
à un aménagement judicieux des espaces
privés et des espaces collectifs
des solutions sont trouvées qui
permettent de concilier liberté et
indépendance avec en même temps les
avantages indispensable d'une vie
sociale animé varié est proche
place donc à l'urbanisme naturel dit le
chef de l'état plus de site est composé
de pavillons identique alignés les uns à
côté des autres sans un arbre plus de
clapiers non plus selon les propres mots
de valéry giscard d'estaing l'urbanisme
doivent changer et précisément si l'on
regarde les chiffres concernant la
construction en 1976 on s'aperçoit que
le rêve de beaucoup de français de
posséder leur petite maison à eux est en
train de devenir peu à peu réalité un
très net mouvement se dessine en faveur
des constructions de maisons
individuelles même si ce choix peut
présenter aussi quelques inconvénients
maisons individuelles ou logements
collectifs pour les français l'aspect le
plus concret d'une réforme de l'habitat
se résume à ce choix
et encore ce n'est pas toujours un choix
car l'accès à la maison individuelle
coûte cher pourtant il ya en france
c'est certain une aspiration vers ce
type d'habitat aspirations ont
concrétisé par les chiffres
en 76 pour la première fois on a
construit plus de maisons individuelles
que deux logements collectifs
cette tendance n'est d'ailleurs pas
propre à la france on la constate dans
tous les pays libéraux qui ont un niveau
de vie élevé
exemple si en tchécoslovaquie 26 %
seulement des habitants vivent dans des
maisons individuelles aux états unis au
contraire le pourcentage est inversée
pour atteindre près de 80% en france
pour l'instant la maison individuelle ne
représente actuellement que 40% de la
ville
reste à savoir quelles maisons
individuelles car le développement
anarchique de ce type d'habitat présente
lui aussi des dangers
sa présence les dangers exactement
d je dirais des excès qui ont pu être
accomplis en matière d'habitat collectif
un habitat rectangulaire gigantesque
uniforme humains dans le cadre de ce qui
a été ratée en matière de logements
collectifs le danger inverse c'est un
paysage complètement mitée par des
petits champignons
c'est un urbanisme dégrader c'est des
difficultés pour les relations sociales
ça c'est la caricature de la maison
individuelle alors ce qu'il s'agit de
faits c'est que la maison individuelle
si elle se développe
puis se développer sans ces dangers la
construction anarchique paysage défiguré
le danger est important d'autant que 6
25% des maisons sont l'oeuvre de
promoteurs qui vendent des villages
regroupés et 31 % sont des modèles
vendus sur catalogue
le reste c'est à dire près de la moitié
sont bâtis par des artisans ou les
futurs occupants eux mêmes
il peut y avoir alors le meilleur mais
aussi le pire reste enfin le problème du
coup la maison individuelle revient plus
cher à la collectivité canalisations
travaux de voirie tout cela coûte cher
d'autant plus cher que l'habitat est
plus dispersée
d'où la volonté des pouvoirs publics de
s'orienter avec cette réforme de
l'urbanisme vers une formule
intermédiaire de maisons complètement
groupés ou bien vers les lotissements
dont la réglementation vient d'être
profondément modifié pour en faciliter
le développement
mais tout cela ne se fera que très
lentement car en matière d'urbanisme
d'habitat
les changements ne se font pas du jour
au lendemain après avoir donné le
véritable coup d'envoi donc de la
réforme du logement ce matin à l'hôtel
de ville d'orléans valéry giscard
d'estaing a aussi parlé politique et
pour répondre en particulier à l'une des
questions posées par certains
après son discours de carpentras unité
nationale est elle impossible
eh bien mon sentiment c'est que l'unité
nous l'atteindrons et je vous dirais
même sûr et plus loin l'unité jeux
l'atteindrait mais naturellement il faut
un effort persévérant
portant sur une longue période pour
atteindre cette unité et je pense qu'une
des manières d'y tendre c'est de
rechercher des solutions communes
c'est à dire des solutions non partisane
aux problèmes qui préoccupent les
français est ainsi peu à peu la tâche de
l'unité s'étendre unité nationale
souhaitable unité nationale possible
répète donc le président de la
république qui avait déjà abordé ce
thème dans ses discours de carpentras et
du 14 juillet mais il semble aujourd'hui
noël copains que le chef de l'état veut
y aller un peu plus loin encore oui
c'est un thème effectivement qu'il
revient maintenant à peu près dans
chaque discours important ils étaient
lancés ou plutôt peut être relancé à
carpentras ce jour là monsieur giscard
d'estaing avait annoncé qu'après les
élections il prendrait un certain nombre
d'initiatives pour réaliser l'unité
nationale et tout le monde a pensé
évidemment qu'il s'agirait d'une
initiative très politique comme par
exemple une réforme électorale un
référendum ou pourquoi pas les deux à la
fois aujourd'hui monsieur giscard
d'estaing entendu montré que l'unité
pourrait se faire sur des sujets très
précis elle cite notamment l' europe les
collectivités locales et le logement qui
était le principal sujet de
préoccupation de son discours
évidemment on peut se demander si près
celle union en pleine période électorale
ou du moins pré électorale ce n'est pas
un peu contradictoire comme cela se dit
à gauche ou si ce n'est pas des
mobilisateurs comme le pensent sans
doute dans certains milieux de la
majorité mais ce qui est nouveau je
crois depuis le discours de carpes
l'emprunt c'est que le président de la
république pense qu'il n'est pas
contradictoire justement de vouloir à la
fois l'unité de la nation et la victoire
de la majorité dans la mesure où elle
estime qu'il est lui le mieux placé pour
réaliser cette union de la nation d'où
l'importance des mots que nous venons
d'entendre il ya quelques instants
l'unité et nous l'atteindrons l'unique
tes jeux l'atteindre et je crois que
rarement le président de la république
avait employé dans un discours un ton
aussi personnel et puis autre souci pour
le gouvernement l'unité de la majorité
demain comme prévu au siège du cds à 10h
première réunion des formations de la
majorité
ce sera la première réunion de
concertation à ce propos d'ailleurs
raymond barre vient d'envoyer une lettre
à jacques chirac ce soir oui dans cette
lettre le premier ministre explique
d'abord pourquoi il n'aura pas de
représentant cette réunion parce qu'ils
estiment en gros que les problèmes de
procédures électeurs
le son du niveau de la concertation
entre les formations de la majorité
monsieur bart annonce aussi son
intention qui était connue de revenir
autour de lui les chefs de la majorité
dans le courant du mois de septembre
et là il affirme dans quel esprit il
fera cette réunion il affirme qu'il
agira dans le seul souci de maintenir en
liaison étroite et confiante entre le
gouvernement qu'est la responsabilité de
conduire la politique de la nation et la
majorité qui lui apporter son soutien
monsieur bart compte sur le soutien est
sûre le concours de monsieur chirac est
comme sur celui des autres responsables
de la majorité
en somme sur un ton à la fois très
modérée très courtois le premier
ministre indique les limites de la
réunion de demain
et par ailleurs il précise le rôle qu'il
entend jouer personnellement partir du
mois de septembre dans l'organisation de
la majorité dans la perspective de la
bataille électorale
une absence remarquée demain matin
autour de la table où vont se réunir
donc les dirigeants de la majorité celle
de monsieur jean-jacques
servan-schreiber
cet après-midi-là été reçue par raymond
barre à l'hôtel matignon pendant une
heure après l'entretien le président du
parti radical a confirmé qu'il
n'assisterait pas au sommet de la
majorité de main pour nous comme je les
ai déjà dit plusieurs fois la seule
réunion utile pour organiser l'entente
avant l'échéance électorale et celle de
septembre qui sera conviée par le pôle
minier du sila en juillet et en août
seuls comptent les travaux de fond pour
déceler les aspirations profondes des
français et pour y répondre
ce à quoi nous nous employons sans
relâche après jean-jacques
servan-schreiber c'est monsieur andré
henry ge le secrétaire général de la ffn
la fédération de l'éducation nationale
qui est entré dans le bureau du premier
ministre
sujet de conversation aux différents
évidemment puisqu'il s'agissait là de
négociations salariales dans la fonction
publique
à sa sortie de l'hôtel matignon monsieur
andré henry s'est montré relativement
sceptique sur les chances d'aboutir à un
accord en 1977
enfin après midi décidément chargée pour
raymond barre à 18h45
le premier ministre a reçu le président
du conseil italien monsieur andreotti
l'entretien qui sera suivie d'un dîner à
l'hôtel matignon
au menu des discussions sans doute le
fameux compromis historique réalisé la
semaine dernière en italie
c'est à dire l'accord sur un programme
entre la démocratie chrétienne et le
parti communiste mais aussi bien sur les
relations franco italiennes et les
relations de cette nouvelle italie entre
guillemets avec l'ensemble de ses
partenaires européens
il tarde vraiment à l'hôtel monsieur
raymond barre qui a quitté pour quelques
jours le beau soleil romain ont
certainement beaucoup de choses à dire
il ya tout d'abord le problème de
l'adhésion au marché commun de certains
pays comme l'espagne le portugal ou la
grèce
et disons que dans ce domaine les
italiens sont plus favorables que les
français et puis il ya un combat commun
entre français et italiens contre
l'inflation contre le chômage il faut
préciser qu'en italie l'inflation et le
chômage sont plus important qu'en france
mais ce qui intéressera peut-être
surtout monsieur raymond barre c'est la
situation politique intérieure en italie
car enfin monsieur julien dray antilles
est le seul premier ministre d'europe
occidentale qui gouvernent actuellement
grâce à un accord en bonne et due forme
avec les communistes
alors certains diront c'est un événement
historique car depuis 30 ans c'est la
première fois qu'en italie les
communistes participe au pouvoir
d'autres diront attention il s'agit tout
de même d'un accord très limité à
certains domaines précis comme
l'université l'enseignement l'ordre
public ou l'économie il est certainement
trop tôt pour savoir si cet accord va
déboucher sur l'entrée des communistes
dans la majorité où dans le gouvernement
l'italie quoi qu'il en soit à l'heure
actuelle monsieur julian riot qui est
certainement le premier ministre le plus
stable et le plus solides d'europe
occidentale et cela valait la peine de
le rencontrer merci victor ramos
depuis plusieurs semaines les israéliens
vivait avec deux grands points
d'interrogation dans l'esprit la date de
la hausse des prix est le résultat de la
visite de monsieur béguines aux états
unis la réponse à la première question
ne s'est pas fait attendre ce matin en
se réveillant tous les habitants
d'israël où tu droit à la petite
surprise que leur a réservé leurs
ministres des finances à savoir + 25%
sur le pain le lait l'huile les oeufs
l'électricité etc
pour la deuxième question sans aucun
doute beaucoup plus importante pour
l'avenir
de leur pays et les israéliens devront
attendre encore quelques heures après
avoir reçu pendant le week-end les
dirigeants des organisations juives
américaines
le premier ministre israélien monsieur
begin est arrivé aujourd'hui à
washington
c'est demain matin seulement qu'il aura
son premier entretien avec le président
carter envoyé spécial en israël pour le
journal d'antenne 2 claude carey a pu se
rendre compte du changement de mentalité
qui semble se dessiner dans ce pays
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de monsieur
begin en particulier en allant visiter
ce qui reste l'un des symboles de l'état
hébreu le kibboutz cette oasis de
verdure un kibboutz aux portes du désert
du negev comme tous les kibboutz eux
malgré sa semi au sort si il a ressenti
tous les chocs de la société israélienne
fondée en 1946 azéri mme le symbole de
la réussite une certaine idée que
communautaire et socialistes 600
personnes vivent dans ce village dont
l'organisation est chaque année
démocratiquement décidé par tous les
habitants
le kibboutz à conserver l'esprit
pionnier ici tout appartient à tous et à
chacun et la terre propriété de la
nation est cultivée par la collectivité
qui réparti également les fruits
parce qu'il est comme une grande famille
sans travail et le travail en commun pas
le bénéfice de travail et nous en
sommeil parfois gens tout qui fait rêver
de nombreux kibboutz commencer rim se
sont enrichis ils ont développé les
industries de pointe formant ainsi des
unités économiques complète et dynamique
fondée par des socialistes qui veut est
traditionnellement travailliste certains
comme à ses rimes ont cette fois voté
centristes voire à droite
ce virage politique soudain témoigne
d'un changement de mentalité là il ya un
changement de mentalité mais ce qui moi
me gêne beaucoup par la montée du likoud
je dirais mans le pays va vers la droite
dire que les gens sont beaucoup plus
riches tout ça ils votent likoud vie des
rebonds c'est naturel
ils veulent défendre l'intérêt qu'ils
vont vers la droite mais ce qui me gêne
c'est que beaucoup justement d'ouvriers
qui n'ont pas tellement de possibilités
ont voté pour le likoud
je pense que c'est eux les premiers qui
vont souffrir de ce changement
excédé par le chômage par l'inflation
les scandales financiers
le kibboutz a voulu punir les
travaillistes pour leur mauvaise gestion
mais plus profondément encore il porte
lui aussi les traumatismes de la guerre
du kippour ses enfants du kibboutz en
tenue une guerre parfois deux les
parents s'interrogent sur leur avenir et
du même coup sûr leur sécurité leur
capacité de résistance et leur
possibilité d'existence alors que dans
le ciel du kibboutz ronde et bombardier
de la base voisine
une grande partie du karité ou ne veut
pas rendre
pas si c'est une majorité mais une
grande partie une grande fille à genoux
dans les brumes des gens qui ont voté
pour les partis de droite et à cause du
fait qu'ils étaient sûrs qu'avec
béguines on rendrait pas les séries 3 le
passage d'une génération à une autre la
transformation de la société par
l'apport d'hommes et d'idées nouvelles
on peut être également modifié le
sentiment national et les orientations
politiques côte à côte au chant au
restaurant habituel à vie communautaire
les anciens du kibboutz s'interroge sur
le clivage qui maintenant les divisent
et le parti qui les dirigent
c'est un parti de droite
j'ai toujours été de droite contre les
crues et c'est ça chauffe à dire
l'ascension jusqu'au bout mais pas se
répéter mais pour ta pour comprendre il
faut voir c'est elle qui pose pourquoi
on est là pour quoi on a construit comme
on a construit pour comprendre les
choses inspectrice est vraiment une
profondeur pour son compte
moi je vis avec ceux d'après un sou dans
le calme du kibboutz ces israéliens
attendent craignant de voir démodé
dépasser les principes de leur existence
communautaire s'interrogeant sur leur
choix
sera-t-il le meilleur pour la paix la
paix si présente dans ceux qui goûtent
et pourtant encore si lointaine à côté d
énorme dossier concernant le proche
orient le président américain carter
devait avoir aussi sur ceux sur son
bureau ce matin c'était de madère
newsweek en lisant jimmy carter a pu
découvrir l'interview de valéry giscard
d'estaing jean françois kahn vous avez
lu vous aussi le texte de l'interview et
vous en avez retenu essentiellement 3030
phrase qui qui vont susciter je prends
un de très nombreuses réactions vous
allez vous en rendre compte vous même
pourquoi il ya d'abord une phrase dans
laquelle le président giscard d'estaing
note qu'il fait sienne un code de bonne
conduite qui est celui de brejnev
également il consiste à ne pas s'ingérer
dans les affaires d'autrui
et d'ailleurs il discerne un brevet de
sincérité une certaine manière à brejnev
en dix ans les soviétiques ne s'ingère
pas dans nos affaires donc on n'a pas à
s'ingérer dans leurs affaires sous
entendu la deuxième phrase qui est
peut-être la plus importante c'est celle
dans laquelle président giscard
d'estaing note que le militantisme
idéologie vous savez le moralisme un peu
de carter risque de mettre en question
en péril à l'oreille un problème de
traduction de l'anglais de mettre en
péril le processus de la détente
donc il ya une nuance critique et puis
la troisième phrase concerne le
désarmement que c'est qu'un certain
nombre de gens pas simplement d'amérique
en france aussi disent les soviétiques
et c'est en ce moment de pousser leurs
pions de prendre un avantage en domaine
armement eh bien monsieur giscard
d'estaing dit que selon lui les
soviétiques ne cherche pas la
supériorité mais la parité seulement
dans le domaine des armements il précise
même la parité qualitative
donc voyez je crois que c'est 3-1
frappes vont susciter beaucoup de
réactions et je crois que et le monde
qu'il y a entre les conceptions de
monsieur giscard d'estaing les
conceptions de du président carter quand
même certaines divergences d'abord une
divergence d'analysé haut-fond le
président giscard d'estaing et il le dit
dans cette interview pense que la
détente et la coopération économique
avec l'union soviétique risque à terme
de provoquer une détente intérieur en
union soviétique une démocratisation si
vous voulez et du même coup que les
dissidents en tirons avantage n'est ce
pas alors que si on provoque union
soviétique au contraire eh bien on
risque de provoquer en même temps un
durcissement alors que le président
carter aurait plutôt tendance à penser
qu'une politique de détente elle que le
conserver soviétique et de coopération
économiques unilatérales risque au
contraire de consolider le régime telle
qu'il est de consolider le système
brejnev et donc que ça peut nuire aux
dissidents et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que beaucoup de
dissidents pense comme monsieur carter
soljenitsyne cute mais que certains
dissidents pense comme le président
giscard d'estaing comme les frères
medvedev par exemple le dernier point
rapidement c'était aussi une différence
de méthode
le président carter a fait un peu une
croisade moraliste qui pensent qu'il
faut pas simplement l'union soviétique
d'ailleurs qu'il faut dénoncer nommément
une certain nombre d'atteintes aux
droits de l'homme en union soviétique
mais aussi en amérique mais réussie par
exemple alors que le président giscard
d'estaing je dirais plus traditionnelle
plus classique
il pense qu'il faut aborder le problème
globalement des droits de l'homme de la
démocratie qu'il faut également
quelquefois faire des démarches qu'ils
ont secrète mais qui ne faut pas
provoquer qu'il ne faut pas s'ingérer
qu'il ne faut pas prendre parti en
dénonçant tel ou tel fait donc vous
voyez d'un côté une politique réaliste
et aux côtés du petit plus moraliste il
est fort probable d'ailleurs que valéry
giscard d'estaing et helmut schmidt le
chancelier ouest allemand aborderont
tous ces thèmes demain soir puisqu'on a
appris aujourd'hui que les deux hommes
allaient dîner en tête à tête dans les
environs de strasbourg michel meyer en
direct de bonnes autant valéry giscard
d'estaing que helmut schmidt eux
craignent que la confrontation actuelle
entre américains et soviétiques sur la
question des droits de l'homme ne
débouche sur
une réédition de la guerre froide helmut
schmidt qui revient d'un long voyage aux
etats-unis fera donc par président
français les résultats obtenus au cours
de ce voyage
à vrai dire le chancelier allemand n'a
pas été très convaincu de la sagesse du
président américain
autant sur la question des droits de
l'homme et de la détente que sur celle
de la poursuite des livraisons d'uranium
naturel à l'industrie nucléaire
européenne un point de désaccord entre
les états unis à l'europe
par ailleurs le fait d'avoir été flatté
et promu par jimmy carter comme étant le
chef d'orchestre d'une europe politique
et économique n'est pas monté à la tête
du hambourgeois helmut schmidt
il sait parfaitement quoi qu'on en dise
que ce n'est pas encore là un luxe que
peut s'offrir un chancelier allemand
alors quoi de plus naturel que de
partager cette responsabilité écrasante
avec une france autrement outillés et
équipé politiquement sinon
économiquement ainsi pressé par les
incertitudes américaine de leurs valéry
giscard d'estaing et helmut schmidt
semble redécouvrir les vertus d'un axe
de confiance sinon d'union politique
entre paris et bonn au delà des partis
et des différences nationales en effet
c'est réactualisation d'une sorte de
discret directoire européen à 2
s'explique aussi par une grave et
irréversible déception celle que
partagent valéry giscard d'estaing et
helmut schmidt devant une angleterre qui
se déroba l'europe une angleterre qui
plus que jamais peut-être redevient une
île anti-européenne quelques
informations encore qui viennent de nous
parvenir à berlin oui louis ii guy
ringot qui se trouve en ce moment à
abidjan côte d'ivoire le ministre des
affaires étrangères a révélé tout à
l'heure que la france a fourni une aide
logistique au tchad à la suite des
récents incidents du tibesti un petit
peu comme au zaïre des avions militaires
français en transporter du matériel mais
aucun soldat français n'a été envoyée au
tibesti et puis à paris le ministre du
travail christan blake a reçu tout à
l'heure yvan charpentier le président de
la cgc entretiens fructueux dit on au
ministère du travail pour préparer la
rencontre de mardi prochain entre les
cadres cgc et le premier ministre
raymond barre
merci il faut noter aussi j'ai dans
l'actualité aujourd'hui jean quelques
télégrammes qu'en espagne il y a eu peu
d'incidents pour le 41e anniversaire de
la guerre civile la police et la garde
civile avait été mise en état d' alerte
seul un commando de quatre personnes a
réussi à troubler les émissions de radio
madrid en france a noté l'augmentation
des trois quotidiens l'aurore france ce
soir et le figaro ils sont passés tous
trois à 1 franc 40 ce matin
à retenir aussi qu'un jeune spéléologue
de 21 ans s'est immobilisé à 150 mètres
de profondeur
en ce moment même dans un gouffre de
haute garonne pour l'instant sa vie ne
paraît pas en danger et puis en sport
pour la 16e étape du tour de france
morzine chamonix petite revanche de
l'allemand tuera où il gagne l'étape
mais consolation aussi pour bernard
thévenet lui il garde le maillot jaune
et si les grimpeurs espagnols ont
confirmé une fois de plus leur grand
talent les hommes de tête de ce tour de
france notamment van ly pays si raymond
martin avec le portugais regrette idiot
avec raymond delisle avec bernard
thévenet le maillot de leader
tous ces hommes sont restés groupés pour
atteindre chamonix terme de cette 16e
étape pourtant cette étape s'est montrée
fertile en rebondissements d'abord dans
l'ascension du col de la forclaz tuera
aux ex maillot jaune et eddy merckx ont
lâché prise
tu hao va recoller au peloton prix d'un
bel effort mais pas eddy merckx le voici
il souffre de dysenterie il a perdu
toute chance de gagner le tour de france
pour la sixième fois avec lui michel
laurent s'est sacrifié pour son
coéquipier bernard thévenet tuera au va
même réussir l'exploit de devancer ses
adversaires du groupe de tête pour
enlever cette 16e étape l'allemand a
encore prouvé l'étendue de ses qualités
et de ses ressources
demain 17e étape chamonix d'alpe d'huez
encore une étape de montagne la montée
vers l'alpe d'huez pourrait faire la
décision en dehors des dernières étapes
du tour de france vous devez noter sur
votre agenda télé de la semaine
un rendez vous important que vous donne
jean pierre elkabbach et la rédaction
d'antenne 2 mercredi soir à 21h30 dans
le cadre de notre magazine question de
temps nous aborderons en présence de
madame weil ministre de la santé les
principaux problèmes touchant à la santé
des français quels dossiers martin à la
réunion seront
or d'exactement honneur question de
savoir les français sont ils bien ou mal
portants on ne sait pas si l'on en juge
par leur espérance de vie elle est bonne
le monde presque plus mais on vit plus
de 70 ans
si l'on en juge par les progrès des
techniques et les recherches on va bien
et pourtant nous sommes 50 millions
d'anxieux 50 millions de malades
hanté par le cancer les maladies
cardiovasculaires et demi les une petite
misère qu'on pourrait d'ailleurs évité
fort bien nous rêvons équilibre il nous
faisons tout pour être inadapté
nous voulons la santé mais nous nous
rendons malades nous prenons des tas de
pilules pour dormir pour lutter contre
la fatigue pour digérer pour supporter
nos enfants une refusant de changer de
vie alors on peut se demander ce que
valent les français bien la réponse est
simple les français veulent tous bien
portants ne pas payer et pouvoir
continuer à se conduire mal au soleil à
table sur la route avec le tabac et
l'alcool alors dans le magazine question
de temps ce seront des remèdes un
constat un peu tout ça on aura plusieurs
films qui montreront comment nous
conduisons mal et puis aussi notre
fringale de médicaments par exemple
touche en quoi ces films et reportages
la santé des français en vacances
la consommation de médicaments fringale
véritable la vie à l'hôpital qui parfois
fort triste qui coûte très cher et
madame diallo en direct répondre à nos
questions et je vous signale à fait
important c'est la première fois qu'elle
parlera aussi longuement à coeur ouvert
depuis qu'elle a hérité de la sécurité
sociale et nous aurons des
contradicteurs et tout ça donc à 21h30
mercredi question de temps
2002 la météo avant de se quitter météo
pour demain au nord de la loire il
pleuvait par moment il est en paiera
tueur était assez basse aujourd'hui par
contre demain il fera encore assez beau
et chaud sur les régions méridionales et
sur le sud des alpes les nuages
resteront abondance sur la moitié nord
de la france où il pleuvra par
intermittence
les éclaircies réapparaîtront cependant
l'après-midi au voisinage de la manche
où les vents seront encore assez fort
pierre-alain vous donne rendez-vous vers
23h10 pour vous présenter la dernière
édition du journal d'antenne 2 je vous
retrouverai demain soir avec plaisir et
je vous souhaite une très belle soirée